We're going to illustrate this
with a very simple example and
here it is, so imagine you've got
a robot that just has two things, okay?
It is a map of a hallway, okay?
So, here you're seeing a hallway and
by the way this little blue dot here,
this is the robot, the robot
doesn't actually know where it is.
We know where it is because
we're really really smart, okay?
Or we work for the NSA,
I hope that didn't cost me my grant.
Anyway, so the,
the robot knows this, this map and
it knows that it, essentially where the
walls are and where the doors are and
we'll assume that the doors are open,
'kay?.
The other thing that the robot has,
is it just has a detector,
a sensor really dumb that
just looks out to the side.
You can even think of it as just
gotta stick and it pokes it.
And it says,
do I hit something or don't I?
And by the way, it's, it's not very
accurate, so he sticks it out there and
sometimes he sticks it this way and
sometimes.
So it's, it's approximately
that direction he just says,
did I hit something or not.
And you might thing that might
be an incredibly dumb robot and
you might be right except
here's a picture of a robot.
I don't want to insult my SRI friends
because this robot actually got pretty
smart but this is the robot originally,
flaky here.
And flaky had down below on the bottom,
these little ultrasonic sensors
that would send out a chirp and
it would respond back.
Did I hit anything?
Or how far away was
the things that I hit?
So, humor me that this is just a robot
that basically detects, just a hole or
just a not a hole.
That's the only thing that it knows and
because it's not perfect in setting
out its, its signal, right?
Just because it said,
the sensor says hole,
doesn't mean there actually was a hole,
right?
And just because, it says wall doesn't
mean it actually was a wall, okay?